howdy how are you uh i'm azim
uh 21 years old you know what you're
doing today uh
i was gonna go on three speed dates also
having like some dating coaches in my
ear right they're gonna kind of help me
along you know
uh to be honest i am terrified of dating
i've only been on like
like really five dates i'll be like oh
god i don't really like me i think i'm
just talking to my pickups annoying now
i think it's just better like if i
like just stop talking i think it's a
lot of self-doubt in myself you know are
you ready to meet the experts
oh yeah my name is eric leonard more
known as the portland dating coach
i'm cora dating relationship expert i'm
marina
um i'm also a dating coach all right
you're doing something really brave here
we've got your back and i think we're
going to bring in your first date
hello hey how you doing good how are you
he's so nervous
i would be too yeah amazing by the way
oh nice to meet you i'm kat high five
you know what though shout out to my man
and i'm gonna say this half the struggle
is even just showing up
my man came through and even though he's
nervous and he's bumbling
he's moving forward so right off the top
i gotta give it some love
because a lot of y'all be hitting me up
what do i do have you tried no
good die alone
whoa your hair looks nice today thanks
i don't like compliments you know that
no i'm not a fan
when i give a compliment it's not about
you it's about me though i know that's
what i said
throwback that's like five years that's
like five or six years ago
yeah yeah yeah that's a throwback yeah
if you guys don't know what video we're
talking about
uh how does it feel to have someone like
telling you what to do is that
uncomfortable
it's really surreal so cat also what
brought you to uh
this thing like what made you come here
you know honestly i still don't know
because i was like this year i'm just
going to do a stay single 2021
okay and here i am going on a date so
new year's resolution never works
that's the takeaway ask her why she
wants to stay single
why'd you want to stay single why single
20 21 you know staying single 20 21 is
more like working on myself
she wants you to step up and talk about
yourself so like i graduated uw from uh
with a biology degree right
nice and like really what i'm trying to
do with that is i'm trying to become a
doctor really specifically like a
pediatrician you know i disregard what
she said about
talk about yourself i'll be honest with
you guys the biggest piece of advice i
can tell you
is ask them questions about them and
push with those questions
i'm not saying you got to be inquisitive
but there's a natural way to go about
conversations where the other person
gets to talk a lot about themselves as
to provide the conversations free
flowing and fun
they'll enjoy and me personally my
advice dudes is you're better off asking
questions
about them than being the one who just
talks about himself out of nowhere
there's times for it i'm not saying it's
necessarily bad but the opposite's
actually better
here's the difference between men and
women a woman who talks about herself is
just sharing a man who talks about
himself is arrogant
yes right so if you just are
volunteering a bunch of information
a woman's gonna be like when are you
gonna start talking about me
whereas if a woman's constantly talking
about her things guys are like
we still tonight we don't have that same
thought pattern
we don't bars i've had so many girls
tell me oh the guy just talked about
himself the whole day
i have never heard a dude say
she didn't ask me any questions about me
then you never heard that never
never never so that's the difference
because it is a big difference
and that's also why i would never take
advice from female dating no
i wouldn't i would be skeptical i'd be
like okay
but who are you giving advice to girls
cool
guys no i don't recommend it at all
i to recommend dudes take advantage i'd
be like
viewing him where are you like looking
to go i i'd like to stay here like you
know you like you know you don't mad
because like you know
be nice to be here all my friends you
know hopefully be here with you you know
too but like
press pause yo he's giving little jabs
i'm mad at that
he shot he went for a right hook when
the person could see through the guard
they stopped coming it wasn't the right
time but
he went for it right he wasn't just
there being passive he shot a shot
and it was a bad shot airballed it but i
respect it
right don't pull a ben simmons where you
don't take any shots in the nba finals
game
conference finals don't be that dude so
respect to him for that oscar de la hoya
okay diego corrales my [ __ ] keep
jabbing let's go
they're not really vibing she's really
quite still
with this whole thing right while he has
this notable animation
i definitely think he's intimidated by
her what about you you lived through
your whole life
oh no i i went to high school in
michigan
it's getting a little bit like uh
informational
bring the conversation to a more playful
place so
thomas what kind of hobbies do i do like
different one you know what do i do for
fun
yeah um i have a cat okay it's my cat's
birthday today
oh my birthday the cat yeah yeah thank
you thank you i'll let you know
okay you don't want your your your
asking of questions to seem like a
questionnaire
what hobbies do you do where do you live
what part of town
you don't go through every sequence
together if you ask about the cat and
she says
oh my cat it was his birthday i'm like
yo dope did y'all get him a cake how
many candles you have to go on yeah
yeah even if you don't give a [ __ ] yeah
and what if the cat's name is casper's
like yo you're just waiting for him to
die like you're already ready for the
afterlife
you can interject humor into the little
funny things and then
it doesn't make it feel like a question
but like a fun review you understand
what i'm saying
so that's where you go with the leading
question but then you
follow up with that to make it not so
okay that's your catch cat what's your
sister's name oh
gemini great no but like honestly i tell
her
she's intriguing and has a little bit of
an edge she's got pink hair
let me just say record that like you got
pinky i like the little highlights in
your hair you know you've seen a lot
more in your life
i'm intrigued by you i'm super intrigued
awkward that's awkward
if you're on the back foot okay and
she's getting an awkward vibe the last
thing you want to do is be like
i'm so intrigued by you looking like you
want and you're needing more
that's not how you turn it around that's
not how you turn around if a girl is
like kind of awkward and feeling weird
for me i'm
like oh my god you're so beautiful no
it's going to make her feel weird
right i don't know maybe it's just me
this advice is bad
yeah straight away from compliments yeah
that's what i'm gonna say
i had a question like that people
question me they're like yo
what do i do like in my language pick up
lion songs
very rough and girls don't reply to hi
if you want to wow a girl you have to
gotta get outside the box
okay don't do the obvious thing if she
has beautiful eyes
don't talk about her beautiful eyes
because they've won because she've heard
that
all their life two it's not her fault
she ain't got nothing to do with that
three every guy
that she's been with or she's seen
talked about her eyes
go outside the box i would actually
avoid compliments that are
obvious if you liking her style that's
one thing if you like her vibe that's
another thing
her eyes or erica things that we like
you know what i mean
but use it like spice you know what i
mean seasoning your food is good but too
much salt is high blood pressure you
understand what i'm saying you know
i i really appreciate that although i
don't know how much of it it's like your
earpiece they're in your head or
i won't reveal that so you'll find out
on the second date
say you'll find on the second date maybe
this is the editing
there was like zero to little no
chemistry hey so let's say
hypothetically when i say on the second
date right let's say like i plan a pity
for you right
would you be into that a picnic
um i'm already like looking forward to
the next like next date
okay okay yeah yeah um
all right okay it's at the end of this
date thanks so much for joining me that
was fun
great to meet you they are they still
talking to you
yeah they're still in my ear but i say
real quick thank you so much for being
you know i really do appreciate you for
sure
yeah okay oh
okay how did that go for you it feels a
little weird like i feel like
almost a genuine i don't know it's a
weird feeling but i feel good i feel
good
yeah what do you think of him so far i
don't think he feels worthy
or feels comfortable
approaching a woman she was in fact
questioning his sincerity a lot i think
if i can be completely honest i'm not
convinced she wants to see him again
captain [ __ ] obvious or is this
really your profession
you guys are trash at your job uh
he doesn't seem like he has too much
confidence what gave that away his
[ __ ] fumbling for 10 minutes
you guys have nothing insightful to say
jesus christ you know what's crazy is
the girl in the middle is actually the
best one
out of all three of these the other two
are you listen i'm sorry there's a lot
of people who are dating coaches okay
who are trash at what they do
who probably don't really get out there
that much
and release this will calm down your
nervous system
when she enters look into her eyes and
do like a little water cheers
you're james bond own it
oh like uh like like this
did y'all bring these dating coaches to
sabotage them do you think this is
cheers that's corny
that's corny hey hi
don't forget the cheers i forgot the
chickens i'm sorry they got they got
they got
me you know they got me in my ear and
like i'll be real i forgot what they're
trying to like they told me to say
something beforehand i already forgot it
so
they're in they're talking into your ear
yeah they're like in my ear right now
yeah
they're telling me to like look in your
eyes and like cheers i forgot what that
exactly meant to be honest cheers
and cheers all right cheers
they're on to something what how did you
get here like i've been kind of like i'm
not gonna lie kind of with a dating
scene for like a pretty long time you
know
what about tinder have you tried tinder
i have uh not the not the greatest
avoid talking about previous states so
that's another bad piece of advice
previous dates are fantastic
conversation starts
how would i tell you talking about bad
previous dates or funny dates
is one of the funniest parts of it
because most of us go through dating and
it's like a
exacerbating experience like we're all
going through it so asking about it is
perfectly fine providing you like man i
also just like hot [ __ ] and we [ __ ]
no but if it's just like man my last
date showed up 25 minutes late and then
expected me to pick like maybe you have
a funny way of talking about it
i often do this on dates where i'll ask
like yo what's your worst date on tinder
and the stories are fantastic because
you it's kind of like our youtube
channel where we talk about something
like terrible that happened that we all
share and laugh about it
it's the same thing yeah so when she
says don't talk about previous dates
do not listen to that advice it's
perfectly fine to provided you do so in
a humorous manner
or tell an interesting story what are
your hobbies what kind of like
split between you know like working like
medical school applications medical
school you trying to be a doctor
uh yeah i'm trying to be a pediatrician
really
[Laughter]
every time you say that you're a doctor
you know people
people like that they like that ooh
doctor
you're going to be a doctor okay that's
one of the best say
you're like that you like you like the
doctor vibe you places i
i like men with money
do you like the doctor vibe no i like
the money vibe
i mean doctor pediatrician
good [ __ ] if they got money we're
talking about why
you want to be a doctor medical system
hasn't like treated black people well
you know like just remember you can
breathe
you can take time to think between
things i want to be that doctor i can be
like you know hey look it's not all
about the people who can support you
people won't be here for you know that
was good advice that was that was
interesting so don't ramble on
take the breaths pauses pauses within
any kind of speech have a good way
of making everyone um embrace the
science create a bit of tension
and also gets you gathering your
thoughts when you're speaking 100 beats
per second going ah
just harling information it almost gives
off an air of
uncomfortableness you know basically
makes you look
uh like you're worried guess you fell
again
what you mean you're asking what do you
got the left is doing yeah
he's cut he's getting his check he's
getting his cut that's right
oh my god that's i was actually
wondering i was like what made him want
to be a pediatrician and that's probably
the best sunset
or flirt more make her feel seen you
know i'm talking to a cute girl here so
he's charming you charming girls love
compliments
ask her what she likes about you and
preface the question by being like
i have a bold question yeah get her
consent on that too is it okay if i give
you a bold
question chris pause press pause press
pause
press pause press pause
did this man just chime in
[Laughter]
do no bro hold up i need to just come up
wow
be in your body you know what breathe
you know what though you know you know
what's sad about this
there's people paying for his advice
that's the saddest part
dating is hard enough as it is you got
goobers like this man
talk about uh ask for consent to ask a
bold
question jesus christ when you say can i
ask you a bold question that's the
consent now you're asking the [ __ ]
do question twice your consent to have
the consent to ask you a bold question
about a bold question
and and it's a terrible question what
what do you like about me like you're
fishing for compliments
it's it's like such a direct it's not
even like nuanced or
flavored setting up for free maybe you
might have been like hey what made you
want to go on this date that's a way
better question than being like
so what do you like about me ugh if i
was on a date with a girl she's like
so what do you think is beautiful about
me it's like [ __ ] i don't know
why why are you fishing for compliments
and you're probably during the sunny
calm down
man this is brutal oh this is brutal hmm
this is how you know [ __ ] got
no gain yeah uh yo i got like a bold
question if you're okay to like answer
it
i'm worried now what you like about me
you know i think your ambition
like it stands out also the hair yeah oh
so i don't know how you keep
it so how next time we go out i'll tell
you all the secrets about my hair
if you want to know more i can tell you
next time you know next time
but yo so for like the next day what
would you like to do you know because
like i just maybe do opinion maybe go
find someone to eat
oh anyway would it be like where would
it be ask her for her favorite type of
international cuisine
what kind of food you like what's like
international food what do you like i
love my
my my thai food tell her that she would
love to make her
a tom yum from thailand and that she is
tom yum oh
no thank you uh tom yum from thailand
and you tell them
yummy i don't know all right you're
gonna make a
a tom yum okay and you tell me
you know like that sounds like corny but
cute
corn you were cute so corny
oh no no
no no that is
not the first time in a video that i'm
actually requesting
youtube to give us like an advertisement
break
like you could put the brick right now
just to give a little breather
i'm gonna say this jesus pro bono
young man if you watch this video dm us
all right i'll give you the resources
i'll link you to good podcast
i'll even give you advice for free
whatever you need
hit us up let's let's have a talk let's
have it i'm sorry you have to go through
this let's do this their advice is
terrible you may not even know it's
terrible
but i'm telling you it's trash can't
have it okay and i knew she was gonna
say it was corny because that's corny
that dating coach he's corny he's corny
as [ __ ] okay
and i could actually see you you're
actually really cool other than your
nervousness
you're actually very vibrant you got it
you got good energy
you got good taste okay so don't stress
it it's going to come together
but i'm sorry that you have to get
advice from these people i promise you
i'll redirect you in a good spot okay
but this is sad tom yum this man yummy
what's your favorite cutscene uh italian
oh i'ma make you some pasta
and meatballs you want meatballs you
look like a meatball
you're delicious no like a meatball it's
corny bro
oh you uh like italian well
i tell you
if they're really trying to get this man
second thing right no if you don't have
that level of
endearment between the both of you don't
be like yo come over to my place for
some
some homey cooked food like coming
they're strong
there's levels if you guys don't have
high chemistry
don't be like hey girl i want to come by
my place i'll make you some pasta
meatballs no you pushing too fast
right especially if you didn't have like
fireworks on the first date on the
second date still go for something chill
and casual
okay if you if you if you macked it on
and she's laughing and y'all going up
like
hey if you want some food yeah i could
always make some of my place you know
i'm saying we could do it
but this is awkward are you saying that
there's levels to this [ __ ]
of course of course you're very charming
and i think you're going to attract just
the person you're looking for
she's not into them at all she's not
into no she's having a good time she's
chilling but she's not into this dude
whatsoever she said corny
stay decisive be like i'll see you at
that picnic
you know what next day i'm going to see
you that picnic all right well great to
meet you keep your charm
keep your charm and continue to be
ambitious thank you so much
yeah reject that was a soft send away
rejection good for you though
we're curious if you ever feel
intimidated by women
i'm not gonna lie sometimes you know i
feel like they can like see through me
sometimes you know
only good things to see
you got this let's bring in sophie
i'm a z by the way your name i'm sophie
sophie nice to meet you
nice to meet you this is interesting oh
no
for sure compliment her i love your eyes
honestly oh thank you
just be genuinely curious about the
person in front of you this is
definitely the type of girl to have
plans all over a room and some plan b in
the closet
what i mean and discount is very free
yeah
sometimes you you've never even had sex
together y'all just making out and then
right in the middle
making out she's reaching her pockets
she got a condom ready he's like what
are we doing
[Laughter]
and it's gonna be safe
because you know i just cleared my
chlamydia last week
you like anime yeah do you oh big weeb
okay that'll make this way easier yeah
they're bonding
they're already doing it i like hunter
hunter if you've ever seen it oh my god
i love hunter hunter i got like the
manga that continues
after the anime ends they have some good
ass fights
do cruella and uh uh he soaked every
fight yeah actually that that's the
fight that i'm talking about
okay i gotta pick that up he's so
excited he's entered
and y'all shutting the [ __ ] up ain't
saying [ __ ] did you notice that
yeah did you notice that that the one
day that was going great is when
it's the one that just shut the head
foot more than that did you also peep
thing
they talked about anatomy and they kept
building on it right yeah they didn't
jump from topic to top
naturally you just keep delving in and
finding it and
you're saying well they both love adam
yeah but it makes sense you cannot love
something and still be curious
you think i give a [ __ ] about animals i
don't give a [ __ ] but when i'm having a
conversation with someone who loves them
i'll ask about why what is it about them
and animals
and then i maybe relate to some
experience i have with animals no i'm
not even confronted
i've been terrified of animals ever
since i was four because i was in a taxi
cab and one was trying to bite me while
i was trying to get out
and you know you find ways to build on
that conversation that's what they're
doing that's it
that's it that's what they call
chemistry
so these dating coaches the one in the
middle is probably the best one out of
the three because her
advice on breathing taking your time
impeccable
right but the other two absolutely
useless
now they're useless let me rephrase
they're not useless
they're a net negative uh but i'm happy
to do i'm happy he made some progress
i'm happy he got better in the advice
about
being calm breathing having you know
taking the time for yourself to be
comfortable in that date solid advice
otherwise i thought the other two
coaches were terrible
but yeah hey man my offer stands if you
ever want to hit us up that's it
you got to do just more stuff i said you
have to go out there more you got to put
yourself out there
and experience you don't even know
yourself in certain situation you don't
know yourself in a dating situation
and you got to learn that it's just a
new experience that you've got to go out
there and
[Music]
experience